Conventional medicine states that chemotherapy can cause spread of cancer to other organs.
Would you agree, and if not, why do you think they state that?
Well, I would agree in part, so chemotherapy, so chemotherapy remember is an oxidizing agent.
By definition, it's really a poison, and people have said in the alternative
community for decades, why would I do chemotherapy? It's a poison.
Well, I know, but that's how it works, and that's why it works, because it's an oxidizing agent
remember, cancer cells are replicating fairly unhealthy cells, cells with unhealthy mitochondria,
they're not making a lot of glutathione within that cell, and therefore they're at a
higher level of oxidative stress within a cancer cell. So a cancer cell has much more oxidative
stress in the cell than a healthy cell does. Oxidative stress over time can cause can cause cancer,
oxidative stress if it's too high can cause cell death, cell lysis. So think of it as there's a
graph, and there is a lethal dose of oxidative stress, so that's a line across the top of the graph.
Well, a healthy cell, you know, it's a very healthy cell making, you know, healthy mitochondria,
making glutathione, superoxidist, who takes caneles, you're getting rid of toxins within that cell,
your oxidative stress is fairly low. You're a long ways away from lethal death, but a cancer cell
is unhealthy. It's not got adequate mitochondrial function, it's got a lot of oxidative stress,
it's really close to the lethal death threshold. So adding chemotherapy to a protocol
then tips it over and breaks that lethal death threshold and the cell dies. So chemotherapy kills
cancer cells. The only catch 22 is chemotherapy doesn't spare healthy cells. So chemotherapy is
going to be taken up more rapidly by cells that are have a higher metabolic rate. Well, that's good
because cancer's got a higher metabolic rate so it's going to gobble up the chemotherapy. Yeah,
but there's other cell lines that have a high metabolic rate. Your hair follicles have a high metabolic
rate. So the hair follicles are going to gobble up chemotherapy faster than your skin cells.
So you're going to have a greater cell death of those hair follicles thereby you're going to lose
hair. That's why people lose their hair when they do chemotherapy. Well, what else has a higher
metabolic rate as far as cell lines? Well, your immune system has a higher metabolic rate. So the catch
22 that is more harmful to us when we're doing chemotherapy is that it affects our immune response.
So our white blood cell count is going to go down. That's why when you do chemotherapy,
you have to get a draw and do a CBC to get a white blood cell count before you're
able to have administration of chemotherapy. Because if your white blood cell count is below 2.0,
they're not going to give it to you. And there's different medications that they can give you that
can boost the white blood cell count. So then you can come back tomorrow or the next day and we can
do the chemotherapy and not be off schedule. But why is the person's white blood cell count down,
suppressed, whether they do chemotherapy because your immune system is a highly metabolic system and
will uptake more chemotherapy. And it's going to destroy those cells. But it can damage other cells.
It's going to cause oxidative stress to other cells. If those cells are already fairly ill for some
of their reason, it could cause death to those cells. And then you're going to have endotoxins
that you're going to feel sick and that's part of the malaise you feel and you feel cruddy,
you feel like you're going to throw up and it's all the symptoms that you get with chemotherapy.
But cells that are more healthy, it's going to cause a lot of oxidative stress and that oxidative stress
inside the cell caused by the chemotherapy now could be a cause of cancer. So it creates an unhealthy
system. So the catch 22 of chemotherapy is that it works to kill cancer for a lot of people,
but it also works to damage other cells and it could set you up for cancer, could set you up for
lysis, could set you up for other symptoms. Therapies that are oxidative, which are most
alternative therapies are oxidative, you're going to do B17 or you're going to do protocellular,
you're going to do IV vitamin C, you're going to do, there's a lot of different cell, different
therapies in the alternative spectrum that are oxidative. They do the same thing as chemotherapy,
except they don't damage, they don't cause oxidative stress to healthy cells.
If you didn't have cancer and you just went and did IV vitamin C, let's pretend you said as an example,
you're not going to create cancer because you're using an oxidative therapy because vitamin C,
though it's oxidative, is not oxidative to healthy cells. So it spares healthy cells. So can conventional,
why does conventional medicine state that chemo could cause a spread of cancer? Because it can,
does it do that? And everybody does everybody have chemo therapy and if getting cancer somewhere else,
they end up with more metastasis, they end up with secondary, primary cancers. No, they don't because
you have an immune system that will recover and will fight that and you're doing other things that
are fighting against that to try to boost this and try to build your body back up. So you're doing
everything again, you're to help come back at that. So they aren't just being honest and I'm surprised
that you see that stated because for years, I don't know where you saw that stated because for years,
they don't admit to that. Just like they don't admit to you doing biopsies could cause the spread of
cancer, but it's been proven through their own research. So, but they still, most oncologists will
admit to that.